o latitude pessoal daqui quem falou dar
que sejam muito bem vindos já mais um
vídeo e hoje o conselho diz é não
comerem enquanto ver este vídeo porque
simplesmente este vídeo vai ser nojento
unha encravada é isso mesmo pessoal hoje
nós vamos fazer uma pressão uma unha
encravada por isso afasta um prato de
comida se vocês são como eu que como
enfrenta o psv vídeos não faça o
hospital por favor mas vamos lá então
começar a rolar senhor aníbal on caiu
para explicar agora o que tem que fazer
nesta pressão supostamente
um aqui parece uma fonte que é isso meu
ok eu treino muito pior em relação a
esta lei cósmica eu tava explicar aqui
as causas de um porque dão ia ficar
assim né
o leão de ouro com assim a única coisa
que eu percebo e se for diabético não
posso mover a minha unha e vou ter que
ter as minhas luvas de tirar a unha ok
pessoal vamos pensar vamos pensar que
está muito inchado meu o que tem que
fazer agora tem que passar esta coisa
aqui é isso o que estamos a passar um
desinfetante qualquer que eu chamo de
betadine acho eu acho que a metade em
novos em ok já passamos disto tudo e
agora é contínuo ok não eu não sei por
que continua tudo bem também mas pelo
sim pelo não
eu não tenho outro dele espera voltar
que já haja sair vou ter que injetar
isso aqui não não espero um jeito tudo
anda injetá como é que eu faço isto aí
sim o gato é um cara já tá aí uma coisa
aliás a nokia e tudo bem
anders preto isso lhe meu pai eu não
consiga acertar no buraco meu carro não
é isso estou pensando em casar ali sim
apronto toca agora sim e é e será meu
dedo do erro que a união possa cortar
porque na animação que o anteriormente
no lobby e estava cortada por isso
enfiar a tesoura lhe meu eu vou encher a
tesoura lei e não por pioneer pior e
pior é para pior e não vou ver isso não
vou ver
omar fokinha o caixa não é assim tão
nojento
ok era para agora precisa passar o
paninho é ok isso não vai passar em um
pano e da carne viva causa uma infecção
eu estava disputando uma infecção na
unha primeira isto como ele mesmo o
[Música]
batata a não foi bem pior
agora vou ter que me muito ver uma faca
nós precisamos biótico e essas coisas
com água e agora nós vamos procurar um
olho porque tem muita coisa mesmo eu não
sei se vou arrancar lhes vão ter outro
sócio que ela parece um homem nem houve
alturas ousei vou encarar córnea
acho que aquela bolinha que está cá fora
ou é só parte preta não tenha certeza a
mesma coisa e aquela coisinha que tá lá
fora transparente para este mandou
equipes espingarda que alguma coisa é o
que se sorocaba estão se tornando mais
tarde vou abrir o olho dela parece
aquelas ilhas do sol meu foco eu vou
tocar numa tela com aquela coisa de
ferro que poderiam ter visto aqui eu vou
cortar aquela coisa né
é o nome como é que isto pode funcionar
assim meu nome como é que como é que
isto pode funcionar não nana isso não
foi um choque
ok ok eu pensei que fosse mais grave a
depressão ao topo da tabela o banco
fazer isto mal meu eu vou fazer disto
uma das poucas que olha é um olho meu
que chega a entrar por dentro do olho
por isso tranquilo que não faz com que
fazer espanhóis que mostrar o eleitor
era só isto
ok agora já consigo ver bem isso esta
médica definitivamente fala muito outro
médico não falo tanto eu e vamos ficar
por aqui com espírito pessoal espero que
vocês tenham gostado apesar de o vídeo
ter sido gente não é
espero que não tenha causado gomes mas
sei se vocês querem ver mais vídeos
deste ano cinco pinos gente é e bizarros
de opressões deixem nos comentários
pessoal a vossa opinião sobre este vídeo
isso querem ver mais
deixem-me o vosso apoio óbvio não é like
favorito fiquem bem e até a próxima